RINGO HAD AND START --
THE APPROPRIATIONS AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME THE AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
WE HAVE SEVEN BELLS SH.
THANK YOU WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS AFTERNOON NOTING
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL GO
AHEAD AND START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE --
CENTER DELI ON I THINK WE'RE
GONNA START WITH YOU.
LAST TIME PICKING FIRST.
THAT'S IT THAT'S IT THIS IS THE
LAST TIME YOU GET THIS
[inaudible]
COURTESY.
ALRIGHT SP FOUR SIXTY WILL AND
ENJOY A DO PASS AS AMENDED SINCE
WE ENOUGH PEOPLE HERE TO VOTE ON
IT WOULD YOU LIKE PROCEED
[inaudible]
LEAGUES --
PUT THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED
ITSELF BILL FOR SIXTY I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ARE
PRESENTED TODAY --
BY COMMITTEE A ONE I THINK
YOU'RE MUCH WITH.
BEFORE THE STAFF --
TO OUR TO WORK ON THIS MEASURE
UP LIMIT I'LL OCCURRED TO CHASE
OF VERY QUICK FIX AND WE HAVE
OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO WANT TO
PRESENT THEIR BILLS I KNOW FOLKS
WANNA.
GET ALONG AND GET GET GOING WITH
THEIR MONDAY EVENING HERE BUT
LET ME SAY THAT SYMBOL FOR SIXTY
DOES NOT A CREATE ANY NEW
VEHICLE TOWARD DEMOCRACY.
IT FOCUSES ENSURING THAT NET
NEUTRALITY VIOLATORS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM ENTERING INTO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
NOT IN THE TELECOM BUSINESS WE
SUBCONTRACT IF YOU WILL WITH
INTERNET SET --
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THE INTERNET A INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS ISPS AND HERE TO NET
NEUTRALITY PRINCIPLES.
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
THEREFORE MADAM CHAIR --
MISTER VICE CHAIR I WAS UGLY
* FOR NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU --
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
I I GUESS BEFORE WE GET SPEAKERS
AND SUPPORT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT I READ OFF THE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE THIS IS TO
PASS AS MEN MEANT.
ANNA HAS AGREED TO EMPIRE SEEN
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AND THAT DOES INCLUDE LIMIT THAT
CLARIFICATION REQUIREMENTS TO
ONLY THOSE BROADBAND INTERNET
ACCESS SERVICE CONTRACTS WORTH A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
MORE.
PROVIDE LIMITED EXCEPTIONS
OCCASION REQUIREMENT TO MOVE THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS TO CHAPTER.
THREE OF THE PUBLIC CONTACT
COACH RELYING EXISTING STATUTES
GOVERNING IT AND
TELECOMMUNICATION CONTRACTS AND
YOU ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS
CRACKED.
SPENT OKAY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEJO ANOTHER
NUMBER PER SAYING THAT'S AN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT --
TRACE SEEM TOURISM BURKE OQAM
PRIVACY.
AND ARE EXCUSE ME.
CAN MEDIA ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
BOTH STRONG.
I'M SURE MEMBERS CRISTINA MOM
BEHALF OF THE WRITERS GUILD OF
AMERICA WEST IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEN EL [inaudible]
DIVINE [inaudible]
ATTY -- WE
DO OPPOSE AS MANY OF MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MAY KNOW
[inaudible]
THE FILLED LEVINE REPRESENTING A
TNT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
THOUGHT WE JUST WANNA MAKE A
COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS I THINK
FIRST AND FOREMOST --
AS WE TESTIFIED PREVIOUSLY
EIGHTEEN T. DOES SUPPORTED OPEN
INTERNET.
OUR WE DO BELIEVE SP FOUR SIXTY
ADDS NEW COMPLICATIONS AT NO
COST TO THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
AS MANY THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MAY ALREADY KNOW.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
PROCUREMENT PROCESS REQUIRES ALL
CONTRACTORS APPLY WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW.
ADDING NET NEUTRALITY IS NOT
PART OF THE OBAMA FCC ORDER.
AND WE BELIEVE IT ADDS
ADDITIONAL COMPLICATIONS AT
REQUIRING THE STATE TO DEVELOP
CERTAIN EXPERTISE ARE IN THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS SO YOU
EXPENSE YOU AYE DELAY AND YOU
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PROTEST.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY WE WOULD RECOMMEND THE
COMMITTEE REJECTED THE MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS STEEP CARLSON CTA
WHERE THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY
TRADE ASSOCIATION --
SP FOUR SIXTY IS TIED TO S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO ABOUT WHICH
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD --
AND THAT GOES WE BELIEVE WELL
BEYOND --
THE OBAMA TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER
DESPITE THE THE CLAIM TO THE
OPPONENTS THAT'S ALL THAT'S ALL
THAT THEY'RE DOING.
SO IN IN MANY WAYS IT GOES A
BEYOND WHAT THE PROPONENTS ARE
SAYING IT DOES --
CENTER DELAY OWNS BILL ADDS
ANOTHER LAYER LAYER OF
COMPLICATION BY BRINGING IN
PROCUREMENT SO AGAIN IT GOES
WELL BEYOND THEIR SO FOR THOSE
REASONS AND THE REASON STATE BY
MISTER DIVIDE WE OPPOSED.
I THINK YOUR THEIR ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE ENDS OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MADAM.
HOW GET YOU?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M ADDICTED
MCCARTY HERE OF THAT HAVE
[inaudible]
BEHALF OF I'D YOU PERSONALLY ON
BEHALF OF VERIZON IN OPPOSITE.
IT'S THE REASON PATH TO MOBILE
ENOUGH THAT.
MARGARET LET YUBA HAVE COMCAST
OPPOSITION.
PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS AND
CAL CALM IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OUR FINANCE [inaudible]
A GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JULIAN AT AIR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE MEN SERVING
TAKEN AND COMMITTEE TODAY I
WOULD NOTE THAT IN THE PRIOR
VERSION OF THE BILL WE WERE
OPPOSED --
AS WE NOTED THE BILL COULD
CREATE SUBSTANTIAL COST TO THE
STATE THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY ONE MORE IN OPPOSITION
GAS.
CAROLINE MCINTYRE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND
KEPT.
AS I'M NOT GO AHEAD AND PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT TO TAKE --
ROLE XFF [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW PRESIDENT BLOOM
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BRO HERE CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK HERE REYES.
AND IT BE OUTSTANDING IF MISTER
BONTA OR MISTER OUT WE'RE GOOD
MISTER CAL SAVES THE DAY.
DO I HEAR MOTION ON THIS BILL.
AND I HAVE A MOTION --
BY MISS CLEO SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK I'LL.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS SEEN
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE BIG ADVENTURE IT'S AN HONOR
MISS VICE CHAIR I'VE SURPLUS
WHENEVER.
THANK YOU TO GET OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
I HAVE [inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
GLAZIER.
SURE GLAZER SP TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
AM MOTION BY MISS RATES IN A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO --
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD GIVE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS MANY THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THAT OUR
COUNTRY'S TRUTH IN LENDING LAWS
HAVE GIVEN CONSUMERS MORE THAN
HALF A CENTURY.
I'VE REQUIRE LENDERS AND OTHER
FINANCE COMPANIES PROVIDE CLEAR
AND CONSISTENT DISCLOSURES TO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHEN THEY
OFFER THEM FINANCING.
AND WHEN THEY CLOSE THE IDEAL.
I KNOW THAT THERE REMAINS
DESPITE THAT GREAT AMOUNT OF
WORK THIS YEAR SOME OPPOSITION
REMAINING.
AND DEPENDING ON THAT COMMENTS
THEY MIGHT MAKE I CAN GO INTO
FURTHER DETAIL.
BUT I THINK YOU SEE FROM THE
ANALYSIS IT JUST REQUIRES THE
DISCLOSURE OF SIX BASIC
ELEMENTS.
REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE COST OF
MONEY -- AND
THE MOST IMPORTANT ONE IS A I
DISCLOSURE THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
COMPARISON SHOP AS A SMALL
BUSINESS PERSON FROM.
ONE LENDER TO ANOTHER --
AT THIS SMALL.
LENDING OUT MARKET IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE INTO
BUSINESSES I DON'T WANNA AFFECT
THAT IT HURT IT.
I'M BUT I THINK WE FOUND THE
RIGHT CHORD.
AND AS I IN THIS LEGISLATION
THAT'S BEFORE YOU THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE.
AND TOO MANY THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THE WORK THEY'VE DONE TO
HELP US MOLD THIS BILL TO WHERE
IT IS TODAY HAVE.
TWO EYEWITNESSES THAT TO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SUPPORTERS
AT CAROL LENA MARTINEZ THE CEO
OF CALIFORNIA SUSHI XIN OF
MICROENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY.
AND LOUISE AT QUE DIETZ PACK OF
THE LENDING CLUB THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION HOW OUR MIND
FOLKS THIS IS A DO PASS HAS A
MOTION A SECOND AND IT'S LATE --
AND SO IF WE CAN JUST MAKE SURE
WE SPEAK ONLY TO THE FISCAL.
QUESTION OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
MAY PROCEED.
WELL THANK YEAR TREK GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND COUNTY MARTINEZ
AND THE CEO OF THE TIME YOU KNOW
AND IT'S VOICE FOR MICRO
BUSINESS SAYS IN CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE SMALL BUSINESS LENDERS
AGENCIES THE SMALL BUSINESS
TRAINING PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
SERVING FIFTY THOUSAND BUSINESS.
OWNERS --
I'M HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU WHY
S. B. TO AUTHORED FIGHTS I'M
POOR AND THIS SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCING HAS CHANGED IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AND BUSINESS I
STILL STRUGGLE TO GET THE LUNGS
FROM TRADITIONAL LENDERS --
NEW TYPES OF PHONE LINES CALLING
FINANCING ARE COMMON FOR OPTIONS
CAN BE A GOOD THING BUT MANY OF
THESE OPTIONS ARE NOT
TRANSPARENT ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY
POTS -- OUR
MEMBERS WORK EVERYDAY WITH A
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE IN
TROUBLE THE BUSINESS HONOR TO
GOD FINANCING WITHOUT FULLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW MUCH IT WOULD
COST.
WHY BECAUSE THEY ONLY LENDER IT
NEVER TOLD THEM?
WITHOUT S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
LENDERS DON'T HAVE TO DISCLOSE
PRICES TRANSPARENTLY AND SOME DO
NOT.
RESEARCH BY CAMEO OPPORTUNITY
FUND --
FOUND SOME CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
ARE PAYING ONLINE VENDORS RATES
OF 94% ON AVERAGE WITHOUT
DISCLOSING THEM TO BORROWER.
WE'VE PAYMENTS ABOUT DOUBLE WHAT
THE BUSINESS COULD AFFORD.
SOMETIMES OUR MEMBERS CAN HELP
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER BUT
SOMETIMES THEY CAN'T.
THEY CLOSE THEY LAY OFF
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR FAMILIES SO.
FOR THE COMMON SENSE IS CLOSER
DISCLOSURES OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE ARE NEEDED TO EMPOWER SMALL
BUSINESSES TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS.
CALCULATING RATES IT'S NOT
DIFFICULT OUR MEMBERS MAKE THESE
CALCULATIONS WHEN THEY HELP WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES UNDERSTAND THE
FINANCING THEY HAVE TAKEN.
THE BILL IS THE RIGHT AGENCY TO
FINALIZE THE DETAILS AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT
INTO THE BEALES RURAL MACON.
I HAVE TO GET PORN SECONDS YEAH
I'M I ASKED YOU TO SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE TODAY IT'S
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE HURTING AND
THEY NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK THANK YOU I MARRY MY
PEOPLE I'M ONLY SAY IF FISCAL
ELSEWHERE WHERE ONLY SPEAKING TO
THE FISCAL ANALYSIS OF THE BILL
TODAY AND NO MORE THAN --
TWO TWO PEOPLE IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK CHAIRMAN JAMES LEWIS GET
PACKED AND THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR LENDING CLUB
BUT IN CLUBS A LOT THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST MARKETPLACE LENDING
COMPANY AND I'M ALSO SUPPORTING
THE RESPONSIBLE BUSINESS ON THE
COALITION.
ON TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO YOUR
QUESTION BY THE FISCAL IMPACT --
I'LL I'LL SHARE WHAT WE THINK
THAT THE FISCAL IMPACT IS IN
FACT MINIMAL ON THE STANDARDS
THAT ARE DESCRIBED IN THE BILL
ARE VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD VERY
CALM AND OF THE KINDS OF OF
CALCULATIONS REQUIRED TO
DISCLOSE THEM ARE SIMPLE UP MY
COMPANY DOES HE'S EVERY DAY
INCLUDING FOR VARIABLE.
RATE PRODUCTS AS DO OTHER
COMPANIES WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE
THAT IT WILL BE EXCEPTIONAL
DIFFICULT FOR DPO TO FINALIZE
DETAILS OF THIS REGULATION.
AND WE THINK THE DB รณ IS
ACTUALLY THE RIGHT ORGANIZATION
AND THE ONLY AGENCY AVAILABLE TO
DO IT SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE WE
URGE STRONG SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
CAN LEAD ON THIS ISSUE AND SMALL
BUSINESSES.
ARE DEPENDING ON IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU PERFECT IN SUPPORT
DENNIS LOW PER WITH THE
AUTOMATIC FINANCE CORPORATION.
A IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR LAURIE
CAMERA SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA
AND OPPORTUNITY FUNDED STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX ONLY TO
REPRESENT A SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE ASSOCIATION WE THINK THE
IMPACT --
EXACTLY SIGNIFICANT.
DEPARTMENT IS THE OVERSIGHT DOES
HAS NO EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE
--
IN THIS AREA THEY DO A GREAT JOB
PERSPECTIVE LICENSING.
AND REGULATING IN THEIR HOME
THOSE UNDER THEIR LICENSE
HOWEVER.
OF SMALL BUSINESS LENDING IS
REALLY NOT IN THE ROOM WILL
HOUSE THE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
HIRE OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS EXPERTS
IN THIS AREA WHICH ARE NOT --
INEXPENSIVE ACTION VERY
EXPENSIVE --
THE BILL ALSO THE ALTHOUGH IT
DOES LAY OUT FIVE DIFFERENT
FACTORS THAT THAT THE BILL NEEDS
TO CONSIDER.
IT'S NOT EXCLUSIVE TO THOSE FIVE
FACTORS SO IT COULD BE FIFTY
DIFFERENT FACTORS DE REALIZING
QUITE DECIDED WHETHER.
WHICH FACTORS ARE GOING TO USE
IN ORDER TO CREATE IN THE MATRIX
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THE NEEDS TO BE DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT --
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN THAT AREA WE
THINK THE COSTS ARE ACTUALLY
PROBABLY CLOSE TO MILLION
DOLLARS JUST THAT HIRING
CONSULTANTS.
AND ALSO REGULATORY WORK THAT'S
NEEDED SO WE BILL FORTS.
GOOD EVENING AT MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAUL BAUER ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMERCIAL FINANCE COALITION
--
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
SPEND COMPLETELY RE WRITTEN
SINCE BANKING OUT WE DON'T
BELIEVE TURNING OVER DPO MAKE
SENSE WE THINK IT IS EXPENSIVE
FOR THE STATE TO DO THAT --
AND WE DON'T THINK AN ANNUALIZED
--
PERCENTAGE RATE WORKS FOR
VARIABLE PRODUCTS IN THE WAY
THAT THE CENTER HAS DESCRIBED WE
BELIEVE IN DISCLOSURE WE JUST
THINK THE ANNUALIZED METRIC IT'S
THE WRONG WAY TO GO.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
ANTICIPATES MINOR AND ABSORBABLE
COSTS.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
WHICH I TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES MISTER GLAZIER WHO WOULD
MINOR INEXORABLE COSTS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THE SUPPORT AND WITHIN LETTING
BILL.
THANK YOU AND THIS GUY GETS OUT
WITH THE THE BILL PASSES WITH
THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISS LEYVA [inaudible] FOR THIS
IS A BILL ABOUT FIREFIGHTERS I
WILL STRICTLY ADDRESS THE COSTS
TO AT PACKAGE IF YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MUCH MIGHT
MISS EGGMAN A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO.
WE WOULD RESPECT FAILS BUT I
VOTE I APPRECIATE THAT SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT MISTER MCGUIRE WHICH
ALSO LIKE A AYE VOTE.
YEAH IRATE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
TERRY MIKHAIL THEIR READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING CAL FIRE
LOCAL WE WOULD APPRECIATE
SUPPORT ALSO.
MEN CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTY VELMA
BE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
BROAD SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
TO HAVE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
AND HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
THAT NOTES THE BILL DOES
APPROPRIATE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME.
MR COURT THANK YOU --
JUST BRIEFLY Y. CSU. FOR THE
GRANT PROGRAM WHY THAT
PARTICULAR AGENCY.
I'M NOT SURE WHY.
BUT THE CSU SYSTEM HAS SHOWN
ENTHUSIASM FOR LOOKING INTO THE
IMPACTS ON FIREFIGHTERS THEY'RE
ALREADY STUDIES VIDEO OF
FORESTRY IN FORESTRY MANAGEMENT.
ECOLOGY CLIMATE CONSERVATION
CONSERVATION BIOLOGY WHAT THIS
STUDY WILL DO IN THE IN THE UC
CAP ARE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IS ABLE TO GO STATEWIDE
WITH IT.
WOULD BE TO STUDY THE HEART BEAT
THE IDEA THE FIREFIGHTERS UNDER
MAXIMAL HEART BEAT FOR WEEKS AT
A TIME.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CORE
TEMPERATURE SO THAT'S WHAT IT IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE BEST SUITED
TO DO IT [inaudible]
IRATE --
WORK.
THIS HAS A MOTION A SECOND --
WE'RE MAKING SOME ASSUMPTIONS
THAT THIS IS ON THE BUDGET AND
THAT.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THEY PAY MUCH FAN OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
A MOTION ON CONSENT CALENDAR BY
MR PEROT A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON --
AB AND SECRETARY CAN READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ACR TO SIXTY EIGHT AND SCR
REPORTING.
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
I THINK WE HAVE [inaudible]
MISTER BLOOM.
I JUST WANNA REMIND --
IF ANYONE'S LISTENING WE HAVE A
BILL BY MISTER HERNANDEZ AND WE
ARE GOING TO STOP AS SOON AS WE
ARE DONE SO.
HOPEFULLY HE'S ON HIS WAY.
MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU THIS SEPTEMBER AS YOU
ALL KNOW DOUBT NO THAT ISN'T
GOING TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE WERE MEASURED BY MYSTERIOUS
IN A SECOND BITE AFTER QUIRK
DATES GOING TO HOST THE GLOBAL
CLIMATE ACTION SUMMIT AJ ARE
FORTY SEVEN URGES THAT STATE AND
FEDERAL ACTION INCLUDE THE
EFFECT OF CLIMATE.
CHANGE ON OCEAN SYSTEMS AND
COASTAL COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THAT HAD IS ANY [inaudible]
SUPPORTERS.
ANY PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
NO QUESTIONS AND OUT COLD ON
WHICH I GET OUT ON BE WILL CALL
WITH MR OBAMA CHIP OBERNOLTE
VOTING AYE EXCELLENT THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM BACK YOU.
DOES ANYONE HAVE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHERE A DOCTOR AND HIS.
I WOULD SIMPLY LIKE TO A PRESENT
FOR TALK AT THANK YOU MISTER
QUIRK [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THIS ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
IF ANYONE WAS AND HUMAN SERVICES
IT WAS JUST HEARD.
BUT MR ES.
WAS THAT A MOTION.
THAT IS A MOTION AND A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO OR I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT S. B. I ONE THIRTY FOUR
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR HERNANDEZ.
THE BILL SEEKS TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT REGIONAL
CENTER ADMINISTRATIVE MANAGEMENT
COMPENSATION.
ENSURE CLIENTS ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE SERVICES ME
OF MP OPERATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER.
IS TRANSFERRED TO NEW
CONTRACTOR.
THERE'S A LOT MORE HERE BUT I'M
JUST GOING TO ASK FOR A KNIFE.
VERY GOOD.
AND I THINK THE SUPPORTERS WILL
DO THE SAME.
EXACTLY ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF
S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA ASKING
PRINT I'VE THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS [inaudible] ONE
SPORT.
ALRIGHT ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RICK ROLLINS
REPRESENT IN ARKANSAS SHE XIN
REGIONAL CENTERS IN OPPOSITION
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A ANY QUESTIONS.
WE DON'T THINK THAT IS.
CLOSE KNIT AGAIN I WOULD LIKE
AYE AYE VOTE LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU FOR
CITING AND ONCE AGAIN DOCTOR
PARK.
I I'M SORRY TRAPS MEMBERS BUT WE
ARE GOING TO ADJOURN.
WE'RE GOOD WE GOT.
IF I MIGHT [inaudible]
KAMALA.
THANK YOU QUIRK THROUGHOUT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
EVERYONE WE DON'T REGRET
ANYTHING [inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M GOING DOWN ON THE WELL
BECAUSE YOU MAKE IT A PERFECT.
YEAH OKAY THINK